Some businesses and some businessmen just press things further than other people are willing to go. John Nash Pickle grew up poor on a farm in Mississippi, learned to work with steel, started his own company in 1972 with a few thousand dollars. And he did well. The John Pickle Company became a multimillion-dollar business based in Tulsa, Oklahoma. They manufactured these huge 200-ton steel tanks that are used in the oil business and other big industrial processes. Until the 1990s, reporter John Bowe says, when Pickle found himself competing against foreign companies who were stealing a lot of his potential customers.
有些企业和商人只是把事情推向了别人不愿去尝试的地步。约翰·纳什·皮克尔在密西西比州的一个农场贫困长大，学会了钢铁加工，并于1972年用几千美元创办了自己的公司。他经营得很好。约翰·皮克尔公司成为了总部位于俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨的一家价值数百万美元的企业。他们生产用于石油行业和其他大型工业流程的巨型200吨钢罐。据记者约翰·鲍伊说，直到20世纪90年代，皮克尔发现自己不得不与那些抢走他大量潜在客户的外国公司竞争。
Even down the road, a few miles from him, they won a contract that he was bidding for on a pressure tank for some utility company literally 10 miles from his factory. So he saw these companies coming in from thousands of miles away and he thought, well, he just couldn't keep up, because they didn't have all these pollution regulations and taxes and stuff that poor American manufacturers like himself had to deal with.
甚至在他几英里外的地方，他们就赢得了他正在竞标的一份合同，那是为一家距离他工厂仅10英里的公用事业公司制造压力罐。所以，他看着这些从几千英里外赶来的公司，心想自己实在无法跟上竞争，因为他们不需要像他这样的美国贫困制造商那样，去应付所有的污染法规、税收以及各种繁琐事务。
So at first, Pickle decided to do what so many US companies have done. He'd open his own factory overseas. He'd manufacture his steel tanks near the oil fields in Kuwait, in a joint venture with the Kuwaitis. And the way these kinds of factories are run in Kuwait, apparently, the workers aren't Kuwaiti or American. They bring in labor from the Philippines and Pakistan, India and Bangladesh. Pickle hired a recruiting agency in India to find him qualified workers, which they did. They sent two groups of workers, 27 of them in all, to Tulsa for a few months training in Pickle's main plant. And then they were shipped out to Kuwait.
起初，皮克尔决定采取许多美国公司都会采取的做法：他在海外开设自己的工厂。他通过与科威特人的合资企业，在科威特的油田附近生产钢罐。在科威特，这种工厂的运营方式似乎是工人既不是科威特人也不是美国人，而是从菲律宾、巴基斯坦、印度和孟加拉国引进劳动力。皮克尔在印度雇佣了一家招聘代理机构为他寻找合格的工人，他们确实做到了。他们分两批共27名工人送到塔尔萨，在皮克尔的主厂接受了几个月的培训，然后被运往科威特。
And this right here is where our story really begins. In October of 2001, Pickle brought over a third group of Indian workers, 52 men. And these men say Pickle did not hire them to go to Kuwait. No, no, no. They say he was doing something a little more spectacular. He wasn't just going to run an overseas factory in Kuwait. They say he also wanted to run an overseas factory right here on US soil, inside his own Tulsa, Oklahoma plant.
故事的真正开端就在这里。2001年10月，皮克尔带来了第三批印度工人，共52人。这些人说，皮克尔雇佣他们并不是为了去科威特。不，完全不是。他们说他在做一件更壮观的事情。他不仅要经营一家海外科威特工厂，他们说他还想在美国本土，就在他自己的俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨工厂里，经营一家海外工厂。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. You know that idea, "It's not personal, it's business," that what a company does is all about trying to make a sale, trying to stay afloat, trying to respond to market forces in the best way possible. It is not about anybody's feelings.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。你知道那个观点，“这不是针对个人，这是生意”，即一家公司的所作所为完全是为了销售、为了维持生存、为了以最佳方式响应市场力量。这与任何人的感情无关。
Well, today we have two stories about the places that market competition leads two very different firms. One of them, John Pickle's company, makes industrial equipment. The other, in Boise, Idaho, makes local TV newscasts. And in both of these stories you'll hear, things could not be more personal. There is nothing cut and dried and businesslike about any of this, for the people in the companies and for the people who surround the companies.
今天，我们有两个关于市场竞争将两家截然不同的公司引向何方的故事。其中一家，约翰·皮克尔的公司，制造工业设备。另一家位于爱达荷州博伊西，制作当地电视新闻。在你们将要听到的这两个故事中，事情变得再个人化不过了。对于公司内的人员以及公司周围的人来说，这其中没有任何干脆利落或公事公办的事情。
Our show today in two acts. Act One, Cowboys and Indians. Act Two, The Race to Number Two. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分两幕。第一幕，“牛仔与印度人”。第二幕，“争夺第二名的竞赛”。请继续收听。
Act One. Cowboys and Indians. Now, we know a lot about the person who's at the heart of this story, John Nash Pickle. But you're not going to be hearing from him directly. That's because this story involves a court case that he's been found on the wrong side of, and his attorneys have advised him not to talk to the press anymore about it. Fortunately, before he got that advice, he'd already talked to a bunch of reporters, including John Bowe, who tells his story in his book, Nobodies, and who put us onto this story.
第一幕，牛仔与印度人。现在，我们对故事核心人物约翰·纳什·皮克尔了解很多。但你不会直接听到他的声音。那是因为这个故事涉及一场他处于败诉方的法律诉讼，他的律师建议他不要再就此事向媒体发表意见。幸运的是，在得到这个建议之前，他已经接受了包括约翰·鲍伊在内的多位记者采访，鲍伊在他的书《无名氏》（Nobodies）中讲述了他的故事，并向我们推荐了这个题材。
Now, as John Bowe explains in his book, back in 2001, John Pickle had an Indian company recruit 52 men for  him to bring over to the United States.
正如约翰·鲍伊在书中所解释的那样，早在2001年，约翰·皮克尔就通过一家印度公司招募了52名工人，把他们带到美国。
And all of them swore in affidavits that they were promised that they were going to come to the US, they were going to be working for at least two years, they were going to be given medical insurance, driver's licenses. They would eventually be given the means to obtain a green card and get their families over there.
他们所有人在宣誓书中都发誓，他们被承诺来到美国后将至少工作两年，并将获得医疗保险和驾驶执照。他们最终将获得获取绿卡的途径，并将家人接到美国。
John Pickle himself says, you're going to hire for the John Pickle company in America. He said that it's going to be in the United States.
约翰·皮克尔本人说，你们将为美国的约翰·皮克尔公司工作。他说是在美国境内。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] had a great job, what Indians call a permanent job. It's like a tenured position, but in a factory. He had over a decade's experience when he took a position with John Pickle. He also had a new baby. Pickle flew to India himself to interview the recruits, shake their hands, make small talk about their families. He could be charming. And the Indians were impressed that the owner of the operation would go to the trouble to meet them.
他曾拥有一份很棒的工作，印度人称之为“永久工作”。这就像工厂里的终身职位。他在为约翰·皮克尔工作时已经有十多年的经验。他还有一个刚出生的婴儿。皮克尔亲自飞往印度面试应聘者，握手交谈，谈论他们的家庭。他很有魅力。印度人对工厂老板亲自跑来面试他们感到印象深刻。
He mentioned about the good accommodation [? of the ?] facility. And you guys have internet facility and the phone facility. You guys have 24-hour-- all the channels you can watch. Especially he mentioned about the different channels, you know, bad channels and stuff.
他提到了良好的住宿设施。你们伙计有互联网设施和电话设施。你们有24小时频道——所有你能看的频道。他特别提到了不同的频道，你知道，坏频道之类的。
Bad channels?
坏频道？
Oh. He mentioned about porno movies. And I didn't know, regularly, at that time, what was a porno. So he said, it's bad channels. And you can watch.
哦，他提到了色情电影。那时候我并不知道什么是色情，所以他说，那是坏频道，你可以看。
But before their plane left the ground, a few things happened that made the men kind of nervous. They noticed that the visas to go to America that Pickle had gotten them were only for six months. And the visas classified them as trainees, not as real workers. They were told this was just a formality. It was just a month after September 11th, and this was the only way to get them visas. It would be fixed later, which seemed reasonable to them. And a couple days later, they were in Oklahoma. Again, John Bowe:
但在飞机起飞前，发生了一些让工人们感到不安的事情。他们注意到皮克尔为他们办理的赴美签证有效期只有六个月。签证将他们归类为“实习生”，而不是正式工人。他们被告知这只是例行公事。那是在9/11事件发生后仅仅一个月，这是获得签证的唯一方法。以后会解决的，这在当时对他们来说似乎很合理。几天后，他们到了俄克拉荷马州。再次请听约翰·鲍伊讲述：
And of course, they were surprised when they got to the factory in Tulsa and there is John Pickle's wife. She collected their passports as they left the bus. And some of them had the temerity to ask, well, why are you taking our passport? And again they were assured, this is just a formality. Since September 11th, blah blah blah, we have to do this.
当然，当他们到达塔尔萨的工厂看到约翰·皮克尔的妻子时，他们很惊讶。她从巴士上下来时收走了他们的护照。其中一些人有胆量问，为什么要拿我们的护照？他们再次被保证，这只是例行公事。因为9/11事件，巴拉巴拉，我们必须这么做。
And then they're shown to makeshift barracks that have been built for them inside the factory. Dozens of bunk beds squeezed together, barely room between them to walk. The walls were flimsy partitions that didn't reach the ceiling. A bathroom on the other side. Again, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
然后他们被带到了为他们建在工厂内的简易营房。几十张上下铺挤在一起，中间几乎没有行走的空间。墙壁是够不到天花板的脆弱隔板。另一边是个浴室。再次请听受访者的描述。
My bed was very close to where people were taking showers and they go to the restroom. And I was sleeping in the nighttime, and the people would come through from the night shift. And they'd come about 3 o'clock, 4 o'clock. And they'd take a shower. All the water comes out from their wall and spraying on you and makes so much noise. And I told him, I cannot sleep here. And they said, no, we don't have any more beds. You have to sleep here. They put the numbers on the beds. So he said, this is your number. You've got to go there and sleep. You don't like it? Go home. We have tickets ready to pack you up.
我的床离人们洗澡和上厕所的地方很近。我晚上睡觉时，夜班的人会在凌晨3点、4点进来。他们会去洗澡。所有的水都会从墙上溅出来喷到你身上，发出很大的噪音。我告诉他，我没法在这儿睡。他们说，不，我们没有更多的床了。你必须睡在这里。他们在床上编了号。所以他说，这是你的号码。你必须去那里睡。你不喜欢？回老家去。我们已经准备好机票把你送回去了。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] had 18 years experience as a metal fabricator when he came to work for Pickle. He says that, although he was surprised at the living conditions of the factory, mostly he stayed pretty hopeful. He was in America. Soon enough he'd get to bring over his family.
他在来皮克尔工作前有18年的金属制造经验。他说，虽然他对工厂的居住条件感到惊讶，但他大部分时间还是抱有希望。他在美国了。很快他就能把家人接过来。
We just lived there, because we thought, in the beginning, that that was just a temporary arrangement, because Mr. Pickle must be working on that, to find a good apartment or something. So I gave my benefit of doubt every time. I think good. Because I am a good-hearted man, I always think positive.
我们只是住在那儿，因为我们起初认为那只是暂时的安排，皮克尔先生肯定在努力为我们找公寓之类的。所以我每次都给予他充分的信任。我认为是好的。因为我是一个心地善良的人，我总是积极地思考。
But it wasn't just that these men wanted it to turn out happily for them at John Pickle's plant, they needed it to. Most of them had taken a huge gamble, coming to America. Hoping to transform their family's lives and move here permanently someday, they gave up jobs back in India that would be hard to get back, and many of them had gone deep into debt to come here. The recruiting agency in India charged each of them a fee that amounted to a small fortune for them, $2,200 each. And they'd taken out high-interest loans, sold their houses, borrowed life savings from family members. If this didn't work out, if they got sent back early, they'd have a hard time paying that money back. Again, [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
但这些工人不仅希望在约翰·皮克尔的工厂里一切顺利，他们也必须如此。他们大多数人冒了巨大的风险来到美国。希望能改变家人的生活并最终永久定居，他们放弃了在印度很难找回的原有工作，许多人为来这里负债累累。印度的招聘机构向每人收取了一笔对他们来说是天文数字的费用——每人2200美元。他们借了高利贷，卖掉了房子，借了家人的养老钱。如果这事没成，如果他们被提前遣送回国，他们将很难偿还这笔钱。请再次听他的讲述。
Yeah, that's a lot of money for me at that time. And if I lose that money, it would be a problem for me, because I borrowed that money from my mother-in-law.
是的，那时候那对我来说是一大笔钱。如果我失去了那笔钱，那对我来说将是个大问题，因为我那是从岳母那里借来的钱。
How long would it take you to earn that in India?
在印度挣这些钱需要多久？
Oh, there? Maybe 10 years.
哦，在那儿？可能需要10年。
10 years?
10年？
Yeah, 10 years to save that much money.
是的，存下那么多钱需要10年。
Because how much did your job pay, say, in one year?
那么你在印度的工作一年挣多少钱？
Maybe $200 per month.
一个月可能200美元。
As the weeks passed, things worsened. There rarely seemed to be enough food, for one thing. And they were making just $2 to $3 an hour, less than they'd been promised back in India, and half the minimum wage. And they were working side by side with men doing the same jobs for as much as $17 an hour. The company sacked its janitors, and managers tried to force the Indians to clean toilets. As skilled workers with decades of experience, the Indians were indignant about this. Nearly all of them refused. There was other menial work. Five of them moved a septic tank. A few of them did yard work.
随着几周过去，情况恶化了。首先，食物似乎从来都不够。他们的时薪只有2到3美元，比在印度时承诺的要少，甚至不到最低工资标准的一半。他们和拿着高达17美元时薪做同样工作的工人们并肩工作。公司解雇了清洁工，经理试图强迫印度人去刷厕所。作为拥有几十年经验的技术工人，印度人对此感到愤慨。几乎所有人都拒绝了。还有其他的苦活。五个人搬了一个化粪池。一些人干了院子里的杂活。
And one of the most interesting things about this story is the possibility-- and this is a serious possibility-- that company officials and Pickle truly thought they were doing nothing wrong. Again, reporter John Bowe.
关于这个故事最有趣的事情之一是这种可能性——这是一种严重存在的可能性——公司高层和皮克尔真的认为他们没做错什么。再次请听记者约翰·鲍伊。
He really didn't think, I'm just a guy trying to save a buck. He thought, I'm a guy who likes to help Indians because they're starving. Now, never mind that he always refers to them as "the India boys" or "them Indian boys." He told me all these stories about how one of them started crying to him, saying, I never had anything to eat in my life but a handful of rice. And he had been to Mumbai to see the conditions there. And of course, it's true. There are millions of very, very poor people there. So in his mind, though, he was doing a great thing. He was really doing them a big favor. And as he put it, why not treat them like the guests of America that they were?
他真的不是在想“我只是个想省钱的家伙”。他想的是“我是一个喜欢帮助印度人的家伙，因为他们正在挨饿”。现在，别管他总是把他们称为“那些印度小伙子”。他告诉我所有关于他们中的一个人如何向他哭诉说“我这辈子除了几把米什么都没吃过”的故事。他曾去过孟买看到那里的情况。当然，那是真的。那里有数以百万计非常非常贫穷的人。但在他的心里，他是在做一件伟大的事。他真的是在帮他们一个大忙。用他的话来说，为什么不把他们当成美国的客人来对待呢？
Which explains why Pickle had the guys come to his house one weekend and showed them how to fish with a rod and reel, and why, at the holidays, he drove them around to see the Christmas lights of Tulsa, and why, once everything blew up and this hit the local news, there'd be moments like this one.
这就解释了为什么皮克尔周末让小伙子们到他家，教他们如何用鱼竿钓鱼；为什么在节日期间，他开车带他们去塔尔萨看圣诞灯饰；以及为什么一旦事情爆发并上了当地新闻后，会出现像这样的时刻。
Pickle says he's a hardworking businessman and has done nothing improper.
皮克尔说他是个勤奋的商人，没有做任何不当之事。
I'm kind of a halfway [? do-gooder, ?] I guess. I've had many people go in business. I've had people get education. I feel like I went over backwards to help these people, and I'm getting shot in the back. OK?
我想我算是个半吊子的“慈善家”吧。我帮过很多人做生意。我帮过人接受教育。我觉得我已经竭尽所能去帮助这些人了，而我现在却被背后捅刀子。好吗？
And he really believed all that?
他真的相信这一切吗？
I think he really, really genuinely believed that. I mean, I really do think, in Pickle's mind, most of what he did was legal. And as far as the things that might not be legal, well, he was still morally correct, because the shortcuts he was taking were just examples where the federal government was being too intrusive in our lives. For example, he said, sure, I could have paid them minimum wage and let them all find their own houses, but I thought it's probably better for them if I just house them inside my company barracks and don't make them do the work of finding their own apartments. And so, because I'm doing that, I don't really have to pay them minimum wage, because they're still going to be making out anyway.
我认为他真的、真的发自内心地相信这一点。我是说，我真的认为，在皮克尔的脑子里，他做的大部分事情都是合法的。至于那些可能不合法的事情，嗯，他仍然在道德上是正确的，因为他走的捷径只是联邦政府过度干预我们生活的例子。例如，他说，当然，我可以付给他们最低工资，让他们自己找房子，但我认为最好是把他们安置在我的公司营房里，不让他们去费力找房子。所以，因为我这样做，我不必真的支付他们最低工资，因为他们横竖都是赚的。
There was a meeting. They said this a paradise for you.
有一次会议。他们说这（工厂）对你们来说就是天堂。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] says that company officials would even try to say this stuff to the Indians themselves.
受访者说，公司官员甚至试图把这些话灌输给印度工人自己。
Yeah, that's what he said, that you are happy to get this food, because in India you are dying by hunger. But that was not true, because we are skilled men, skilled full-fledged workers.
是的，他就是这么说的，说你们应该很高兴得到这些食物，因为在印度你们正饿死。但那不是事实，因为我们是技术人员，是合格的全职工人。
At this meeting, where the Indians were told that they were in paradise, one of the workers, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE], argued with one of the managers. "When I heard this, I became angry," he said in a deposition later. "We were not dying of hunger in our country. I asked them why they did not tell us in India that they would be unable to provide the right food and accommodations for us. I told him that he misunderstood the life in India, if he thought that we should be happy with the insufficient food and accommodations being provided here. I told him that if he had told us the truth in India, we would not be in this situation, would not have come, and for this reason we would not now be complaining. I told them that to tell us to be quiet now made no sense. He became very angry with me."
在那次被告知他们身处“天堂”的会议上，一名工人与经理发生了争执。“当我听到这些时，我很生气，”他后来在证词中说。“我们在自己国家并没有饿死。我问他们为什么在印度时不告诉我们他们无法提供合适的食物和住宿。我告诉他，如果他认为我们应该对这里提供的不足的食物和住宿感到满意，那他就误解了印度生活。我告诉他，如果他在印度告诉我们真相，我们就不会陷入这种境地，就不会来，也就不会有现在的抱怨。我告诉他们，现在叫我们安静毫无意义。他对我非常生气。”
Within weeks, the company told [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] to pack his bags. He was a troublemaker. They were taking him and another worker to the airport to be deported. Both of them ran away before the planes took off, and lived with Indian friends in America.
几周内，公司告诉那名受访者收拾行李。他是个麻烦制造者。他们要带他和另一名工人去机场被遣返。在飞机起飞前，他们两个逃跑了，并与在美国的印度朋友住在一起。
Meanwhile, back at the plant, Pickle fired 30 of his American workers, keeping the Indians to handle the jobs at a fraction of the cost. When there was overtime work, managers were told to give it to the Indian workers, not the remaining Americans. And all this time, the Indians were in a strange country, whose rules most of them didn't know. When they asked to be driven to a store or to a movie, often they were just told no, and they were warned it was too dangerous for them to go out on their own. Again, reporter John Bowe.
与此同时，在工厂里，皮克尔解雇了30名美国工人，留下印度人以极低的成本处理工作。当有加班工作时，经理们被告知要交给印度工人，而不是剩下的美国人。在这期间，印度人身处一个陌生的国家，他们大多数人并不了解那里的规则。当他们要求被开车送到商店或电影院时，通常只会得到拒绝，并被警告擅自外出非常危险。再次请听约翰·鲍伊。
Theri bosses told them repeatedly, don't leave the factory premises. Americans have a hard time understanding these cases, because you think, were they in handcuffs? Were they tied to something? Was their door locked? In fact, it's a whole bunch of layers of threats that add up to coercion.
他们的老板反复告诉他们，不要离开工厂场地。美国人很难理解这些案件，因为你会想，他们是被戴上手铐了吗？他们被绑在什么东西上了吗？门锁了吗？事实上，这是一层又一层加起来的威胁，构成了胁迫。
They used to say, you're are not going to go out. If you are to go, you've got to get permission. There was a sign put on the wall that, if you leave this place without permission, you'll be terminated and deported back to India.
他们过去常说，你们不准出去。如果你要出去，必须得到许可。墙上贴着一张告示：如果没有许可离开这个地方，你将被开除并遣返印度。
Again, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
再次请听受访者的讲述。
I mean, it was totally, completely, the situation-- you know, out of hand. We were all scared. People were scared to even speak their problems.
我的意思是，整个局面完全失控了。我们都很害怕。人们甚至害怕谈论自己的问题。
Things continued this way until help came from right across the road.
这种情况一直持续到来自马路对面的帮助出现。
The John Pickle plant takes up almost a city block, so our church is on the back side of the factory and across the street.
约翰·皮克尔的工厂占据了几乎一个街区，所以我们的教堂就在工厂的后面，穿过街道。
This is Mark Massey. Up until now in our story, every single person is motivated by the goal of doing better in the global economy, making more money. That's true for Pickle. That's true for the workers. That's not what motivated Massey the day he saw a couple of Indian workers show up for Pentecostal service.
这是马克·梅西。到目前为止，我们故事中的每一个人都是受到在全球经济中做得更好、赚更多钱的目标的驱动。对皮克尔如此，对工人也如此。但在梅西看到几个印度工人出现在五旬节派的仪式上的那天，驱动他的动力却并非如此。
It's a little country-type church. And they came into the church Sunday morning. And they came and it was kind of-- you could feel like they were uneasy and maybe they were, I guess because maybe they weren't supposed to be there.
那是一个乡村式的小教堂。他们周日早上进来了。你可以感觉到他们很不安，也许他们确实不安，我想可能是因为他们本不该出现在那里。
And what happened? You saw them just-- they came in, sat in the back. And did they participate in the service?
发生了什么？你看到他们只是——他们进来了，坐在后面。他们参加仪式了吗？
They did. But the congregation usually will shake hands and try to befriend any visitor that would come in, and get to know them more than just the face or a handshake as they leave.
他们参加了。但会众通常会握手并试图与任何到来的访客结交，而不仅仅是在他们离开时点头或握手。
So Mark Massey approaches the Indian men. And he's a lay minister, did a lot of outreach with the homeless and teaching English in the Spanish community, so he is being very, very friendly. And one of the men who came to this church early on, a vessel fitter with 25 years' experience named [UNINTELLIGIBLE], says that this just made him suspicious.
于是马克·梅西走近了这些印度人。他是一名平信徒，做了很多无家可归者的外联工作，并在西班牙裔社区教英语，所以他表现得非常非常友好。而最早来到这个教堂的人之一，一位拥有25年经验的容器装配工说，这反而让他起了疑心。
I didn't even like that, because John Pickle did the same, like that, with the smiling face. And he did wrong things.
我甚至不喜欢那样，因为约翰·皮克尔也一样，带着那种微笑的面孔。但他却做了坏事。
Oh, I understand. You didn't trust it when the Americans smiled and shook your hand.
哦，我明白了。当美国人微笑并握手时，你不信任它。
Yes, that is right. I am not ready to trust the people, because of all the experience through John Pickle.
是的，没错。因为经历了约翰·皮克尔的所有事情，我还没准备好去信任这些人。
The men edge away from Mark, but he perseveres, invites them back to church, and back to church again, and to a church dinner where one of the guys starts to open up a little.
这些工人们想远离马克，但他坚持不懈，邀请他们再来教堂，又来教堂，并邀请他们参加教堂晚餐，其中一个人开始吐露心声。
He told me that he had a degree in electrical engineering, a college degree in engineering. I thought, oh, wow. And so I said, wow, to bring you from India, you must be making some good money, I don't know. And he told me he was making $2 an hour. And I didn't make much comment about it, but after they had left, I said I must have misunderstood him. He told me he was just making $2, and he's got a college degree.
他告诉我他有电气工程学位，是工程学的大学学位。我想，哇，太棒了。我说，哇，把你从印度带过来，你一定挣了不少钱，我不知道。结果他告诉我他时薪只有2美元。我没怎么评论，但等他们离开后，我说我肯定听错了。他告诉我他只有2美元的时薪，而且他还有大学学位。
Part of the problem  was the men's English was so bad. So eventually, Mark gets an Indian guy he knows in Tulsa, who happens to come from the same state as some of these workers, to come and translate. And Massey finally gets the whole story: their working conditions, how they're not supposed to leave the plant, their fears.
部分问题在于这些人的英语太差了。所以最终，马克找了一个他在塔尔萨认识的印度人，他恰好和其中一些工人来自同一个邦，来担任翻译。梅西最终了解了整个故事：他们的工作条件，他们不被允许离开工厂，他们的恐惧。
I told them, if the situation gets too bad and something happens, that I had a couple houses close to the factory. So I actually left the key underneath the mat, is what I did. And I said, if anything happens, it's a vacant house. I just fixed it up to sell it. I'd bought it and reconditioned it, and was going to sell it.
我告诉他们，如果情况变得太糟糕，发生什么事的话，我工厂附近有几处房子。所以我把钥匙放在了垫子下面。我说，如果有任何事情发生，那是空房子。我刚装修好准备卖掉。我买了它，翻新了它，正要卖掉。
This is actually Mark's business. He had bought a cheap house in this sketchy area near the plant and fixed it up with a partner. And it didn't take long for the Indian men to get in touch, to ask if they could move into the house.
这实际上是马克的生意。他在工厂附近这个贫困区域买了一栋便宜的房子，并和合伙人一起进行了翻新。没过多久，印度人就联系他，问他们能否搬进那栋房子。
They called me and they said that they had to leave. They were afraid the next day they were going to be deporting some people. And they were very scared. So I drove up. I had an eight-passenger van. I drove up outside of the factory. And it was kind of a scary feeling. It was moving a little quicker than I wanted it to. I didn't know just what I was getting into. I didn't know if I was doing things legal, illegal. You still had a nervousness about helping, not knowing if you were violating something. So it was a scary feeling.
他们打电话给我，说他们必须离开。他们担心第二天就会有人被遣返。他们非常害怕。所以我开车去了。我有一辆八座货车。我开车到了工厂外面。那是一种令人害怕的感觉。进展比我预想的要快。我不知道自己陷入了什么。我不知道自己做的是合法还是非法。但在帮助他人时，你仍然有一种紧张感，不知道自己是否触犯了什么。所以那是一种令人害怕的感觉。
It was in the evening, and as I drove up-- they told me to pull up on the outside. There was a little bitty hamburger stand that was shut down. It was closed during the time I pulled up there. There was a phone there you could park by. And I parked by there, and as you watched these guys, they were sneaking some luggage out and bringing it by a train that was set in there. There's a big train track that runs through that area. And they were hiding all their luggage behind the train. And then they were crawling and sneaking and bringing all their luggage into my van.
那是晚上，当我开车过去时——他们告诉我停在外面。有一个小小的汉堡摊，关门了。我停在那儿的时候它没开。那里有个停车可以使用的电话。我停在那边，当你看着这些家伙时，他们正偷偷地把行李运出来，带到那里的一列火车旁边。那个地区有一条大型铁轨。他们把所有的行李都藏在火车后面。然后他们爬着、猫着腰，把行李带进我的货车。
Crawling. He means crawling under the fence that protected the Pickle factory.
爬着。他的意思是爬过保护皮克尔工厂的栅栏。
And there was a Hindu man. He was helping them. His name was [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. He sat in my van, and he knew I was helping these Christian guys who came to my church. So after he had loaded them up, he said, I'm Hindu. Will you help me? And I said, well, yeah. That's what it's all about, is helping each other.
有一个印度教徒。他在帮他们。他的名字叫受访者。他坐在我的货车里，他知道我是在帮助这些来到我教堂的基督徒。所以在他把行李装好后，他说，我是印度教徒。你会帮我吗？我说，嗯，会的。帮助彼此，这就是它的全部意义。
So five of the guys are now out of the factory, never to return. The next morning, Mark went to get the men's passports back from Pickle. And this is when the simmering problem in the plant breaks into full-out open conflict, because managers have got wind of what Massey was doing, and were putting their own plan into motion.
所以其中五个人现在离开了工厂，再也没有回去。第二天早上，马克去向皮克尔要回工人们的护照。就在这时，工厂里积压已久的问题演变成全面的公开冲突，因为管理层已经获悉了梅西的所作所为，并开始实施他们自己的计划。
Mark Massey shows up at the John Pickle Company and sits down with the vice president, Joe Reeble, to beg him for the men's passports.
马克·梅西出现在约翰·皮克尔公司，坐下来与副总裁乔·里布尔交谈，请求归还工人的护照。
And he sits in his office chair, kind of rocking back and forth, and he begins to tell me that we're living in a different time, in a different era, that if companies are going to compete, they're going to have to-- this is how things are going to have to be.
他坐在老板椅上，摇来晃去，开始告诉我我们生活在不同的时代、不同的纪元，如果公司要竞争，他们就必须——事情就是得这样。
Wait, this is how things are going to have to be, meaning we have to steal their passports?
等等，事情就是得这样，意味着我们必须偷走他们的护照？
It's a competitive field out there, and if they're going to work in a world market, that they're going to have to-- this is how they're going to have to do it.
外面是一个竞争激烈的领域，如果他们想在世界市场上工作，他们就必须——他们就得这样做。
And so, while Massey is talking to Reeble, John Pickle is sort of storming in and out of the office, looking really furious.
所以，当梅西和里布尔交谈时，约翰·皮克尔有点暴跳如雷地进进出出，看起来非常愤怒。
And he is totally out of breath. And he was very furious. He was very hot. And just seeing him, you would think-- in my mind, I thought, man, this guy is fixing to stroke out or something. He is just boiling, furious.
他完全喘不过气来。他非常愤怒。他火冒三丈。仅仅看到他，你就会觉得——我在心里想，天哪，这家伙要中风了还是什么的。他简直气炸了。
And what Massey didn't know was that Pickle was actually deporting seven of the men, of the Indians that he had deemed troublemakers, at that very moment.
梅西不知道的是，皮克尔当时正在遣返七名他认定的麻烦制造者。
By complete coincidence, Massey had shown up at the factory on the same day the sheriff was arriving to escort these seven men to Tulsa International. When Massey comes to understand what's happening, he's able to get immigration officials to pull the men from their plane on a stopover in Atlanta. They're allowed to stay in America. Most of them return to Tulsa, where Mark finds them a place to live.
完全巧合的是，梅西出现在工厂的那天，正是警长抵达那里护送那七名工人前往塔尔萨国际机场的日子。当梅西了解发生了什么后，他设法让移民局官员在亚特兰大转机时拦下了这些人。他们被允许留在美国。他们大多数人回到了塔尔萨，马克在那里帮他们找到了住处。
Meanwhile, back in the Pickle factory, security tightens. The men are all warned that anybody who escapes, or tries to leave without authorization, will go to jail. One of the guards starts carrying a gun. To deal with everything that was happening, Mark tried to hire this lawyer named Kent Felty. Here's Mark.
与此同时，在皮克尔工厂内，安保加强了。所有工人都被警告，任何逃跑或未经授权擅自离开的人都将入狱。一名守卫开始携带枪支。为了处理正在发生的一切，马克试图雇佣一位名叫肯特·费尔蒂的律师。这是马克说的。
I couldn't think of no one else to go to. My brother had divorced several years before, and this was the lawyer he used in his divorce case.
我实在想不出还能去找谁。我兄弟几年前离婚了，这就是他在离婚案中使用的律师。
It was really strange. I think I might have been the only lawyer they knew. And at that time, I don't know if I could have spelled immigration.
那真的很奇怪。我想我可能是他们认识的唯一律师。而且在当时，我不知道自己会不会拼写“移民”这个词。
This is Kent Felty, and when he looked at this case at the beginning, he didn't bother with the big questions that it raised, like can you open a low-wage factory with foreign workers on US soil? Or was this human trafficking? No, instead of dealing with that, he looked at what seemed like clear-cut, provable violations of normal laws that most of us have actually heard of.
这是肯特·费尔蒂，当他起初看到这个案子时，他并没有去纠结那些重大的问题，比如你能在美国本土用外国劳工开设低薪工厂吗？或者这是人口贩运吗？不，他没有处理那些，而是着眼于那些看起来非常清晰、可证实的对普通法律的违规，这些法律我们大多数人都听说过。
The men weren't being paid minimum wage, for instance. That's illegal. They received radically different salaries and treatment than the American workers got, so he might be able to argue discrimination under civil rights laws. And when the men interviewed for these jobs back in India, they'd been promised certain pay and working conditions that hadn't been delivered, so there might be fraud.
例如，工人们没有得到最低工资。这是非法的。他们受到与美国工人们完全不同的薪酬和待遇，所以他可以根据民权法辩称存在歧视。当工人们在印度面试这些工作时，他们被承诺了特定的工资和工作条件，结果却没兑现，所以这可能涉及欺诈。
Well, the first thing that hit me was-- I remember going up to the lawyer for John Pickle and knowing that I have strong facts. And if I were in his shoes, I would settle this case immediately. And I told him. I said, look, basically, I've got you. And of course, the lawyer for John Pickle laughed and basically said, no, we're going to club you like a baby seal.
嗯，第一件击中我的事情是——我记得去找约翰·皮克尔的律师，知道我有过硬的事实。如果我是他，我会立即和解这个案子。我告诉他。我说，听着，基本上，我逮住你了。当然，约翰·皮克尔的律师笑了，基本上说，不，我们要把你像小海豹一样打死。
Wait, were those his words?
等等，那是他的原话吗？
Those weren't his words. That was their mode the whole time. They knew that they had the resources and expertise to beat us up. And they did for a long time.
那不是他的原话。但那是他们整个过程中的姿态。他们知道自己有资源和专业知识来击垮我们。而且他们确实这么做了很长一段时间。
Well, and in fact, it's a sensible calculation on their part, right?
嗯，事实上，这从他们的角度来看是一个明智的计算，对吧？
Yeah. We had great facts and that's all we had. We didn't have any money. At one point, we couldn't get-- Kinko's was calling us and saying, you have a $500 order of copies. Can you please come pick them up? And we could not pick them up. We couldn't get copies out. We barely had our filing fee.
是的。我们有很好的事实，但那是我们仅有的。我们没有钱。有一次，我们无法——金考复印店（Kinko's）打电话给我们说，你们有500美元的复印订单。请过来取一下。我们无法去取。我们拿不出复印件。我们勉强凑够了立案费。
Filing fee is just the fee that you give the clerk to submit papers?
立案费只是你交给书记官提交文件的费用？
Yeah. That's $200. And that's embarrassing to say, and I'm sure my wife will be upset that I'm being so candid about our finances, but it was a major hardship.
是的。那要200美元。说出来很尴尬，我相信我妻子会因为我如此坦诚地谈论我们的财政状况而心烦，但那确实是一个巨大的困难。
But the more Kent Felty learned about the case, the more amazed he was at how easily John Pickle might have smoothed things out with these workers. Truly, one of the most remarkable things about the case is how clumsily Pickle ran this illegal enterprise. If he had just given the men regular raises, been more responsive to their complaints, he might have kept them going for a long time. But instead, the Indians testified in court to all kinds of humiliations.
但肯特·费尔蒂对案子了解得越多，他就越惊讶于约翰·皮克尔本可以多么轻易地与这些工人平息此事。说真的，这个案子最引人注目的事情之一就是皮克尔经营这种非法企业是多么笨拙。如果他只是给工人们正常的加薪，对他们的抱怨多一些回应，他本可以让这些工人们长期干下去。但相反，印度人在法庭上作证了各种各样的羞辱。
One experienced welder named [UNINTELLIGIBLE], who'd worked in Saudi Arabia before coming to the US, who'd run a business of his own, described being ordered to clean toilets, which he refused to do. And he then was suspended for three days. He finally agreed to sweep the shop floor, so he'd be allowed to come back to work.
一位名叫受访者的经验丰富的焊工，他在来美国前曾在沙特阿拉伯工作，自己经营过生意，描述了被命令去刷厕所，他拒绝了。然后他被停职三天。他最终同意打扫车间地板，以便允许回来工作。
After half an hour of this, one of the bosses told him, this is not fast enough. You have to do it faster. They went back and forth about this, and, finally, the boss said, this is why Americans say that Indians are a lazy people. He repeats this three times, according to the testimony, and then tells [UNINTELLIGIBLE] that he doesn't like him, and that he's going to punish him. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] told the court how afraid he was. He thought of killing himself. He'd lost all control of his own life.
做完这个半小时后，老板之一告诉他，这不够快。你必须做得更快。他们在这个问题上争来争去，最后，老板说，这就是为什么美国人说印度人懒惰。根据证词，他重复了三遍，然后告诉受访者他不喜欢他，他要惩罚他。受访者告诉法庭他是多么害怕。他想过自杀。他失去了对自己生活的全部掌控。
Many men gave examples like this, of what seems like gratuitously harsh treatment. And one of the biggest examples, Kent Felty says, is something the men faced every single day: the food.
许多人给出了类似这样的例子，这些例子看起来像是无缘无故的严厉对待。肯特·费尔蒂说，最大的例子之一是工人们每天面临的事情：食物。
Back when John Pickle met the workers in India, he made a point of promising good food. And he brought two Indian cooks with him to Tulsa from Mumbai.
当约翰·皮克尔在印度会见工人们时，他专门承诺提供好的食物。他还从孟买带来了两个印度厨师到塔尔萨。
You know, the part of this I don't understand is, why didn't he feed them better?
你知道，这部分我不明白的是，他为什么不给他们吃得好一点？
You know, that is the craziest thing, because this case probably would not have come to me on national origin discrimination or any civil rights claims or false imprisonment or fraud. The men, their primary complaint was that the food was substandard.
你知道，这是最疯狂的事情，因为这个案子可能不会因为原籍国歧视、任何民权索赔、非法监禁或欺诈而来到我这里。工人们，他们的主要投诉是食物不达标。
In the first beginning, he bought some food, Indian food. And then after, he decided he's not going to buy any more Indian food. And he said, I cannot buy your goddamn Indian groceries, because it's so expensive.
起初，他买了一些食物，印度食物。后来，他决定不再买任何印度食物。他说，我不能买你们该死的印度杂货，因为太贵了。
Again, Mark Massey.
再次请听马克·梅西的说法。
It was a crazy thing to me. I mean, had the men had adequate food, they wouldn't have become as discontent, because the food situation-- they worked hard all day long, and in the morning, when they cooked a little omelette with one egg, he would come through and cut it in half.
这对我来说是一件疯狂的事。我是说，如果工人们有充足的食物，他们就不会变得那么不满，因为食物问题——他们整天辛苦工作，早上当他们煮一个只有一个鸡蛋的煎蛋卷时，他会走过来把它切成两半。
No, no.
不，不。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
So each man had to half of a one-egg omelette.
所以每个人只能分到半个单蛋煎蛋卷。
Half of a one-egg omelette. And then there were items that Mr. Pickle bought that he got special prices on, like old bread, old fruit.
半个单蛋煎蛋卷。然后还有一些皮克尔先生以特价买来的东西，比如陈面包、陈水果。
That He was actually rationing apples. He'd cut an apple into four pieces, and a quarter apiece.
他实际上是在配给苹果。他把一个苹果切成四块，一人一份。
After the meal, for dessert, they were given a quarter of an apple.
餐后，作为甜点，他们分到一个四分之一个苹果。
He would ration milk. For the Hindu guys, that's a really important source of protein.
他会配给牛奶。对于印度教伙计们来说，那是真正重要的蛋白质来源。
I mean, I was strictly vegetarian. I had to start eating meat because it was not enough food. There were some of my other friends who were also vegetarian. They wouldn't even eat the-- I mean, hardly enough food.
我是绝对素食主义者。我不得不开始吃肉，因为食物不够。还有一些其他也是素食的朋友。他们甚至不吃那个——我是说，食物简直不够。
And Pickle would mock them and mock them, and say, well, I don't know any grown man that drinks milk.
皮克尔会嘲笑他们，嘲笑他们，说，好吧，我不知道有哪个成年男人还喝牛奶。
The food provider that came to court to testify, they asked him, the food he delivered, how many men it would feed.
来法庭作证的送餐员，他们问他，他送的食物够多少人吃。
The guy testified that, for the 54 Indian men Pickle had brought over, he was supposed to deliver food for 27 men.
那个人作证说，对于皮克尔带来的54名印度工人，他应该配送27人的食物。
So it sounds trivial, but all those things added up to, really, disrespect, I think.
所以这听起来很琐碎，但我认为所有这些事情加起来，真的就是不尊重。
Just moments ago, Indian nationals working at the John Pickle Company walked out. Channel 2's Rebecca Seebirt is following that story for us, and she joins us with the latest.
就在刚才，在约翰·皮克尔公司工作的印度籍员工罢工了。6频道记者丽贝卡·西伯特正在跟踪报道这个故事，她带来了最新消息。
Just more than an hour ago, more than 30 of the men marched off the John Pickle Company premises and went to a nearby house to celebrate their walkout.
就在一个多小时前，30多名工人走出了约翰·皮克尔公司的场地，前往附近的一所房子庆祝他们的罢工。
The disrespect had consequences. Four months after they arrived in the United States, all the Indians who were still living in Pickle's factory finally left. Mark, who is not a rich man by any means, took it on himself to give all these men a place to live, and he organized churches and local Indian businesses to provide their meals. It took over all his time.
这种不尊重是有后果的。在他们来到美国四个月后，所有仍然住在皮克尔工厂里的印度人都终于离开了。绝非富人的马克，主动承担起了为所有这些人提供住所的责任，并组织教堂和当地印度企业为他们提供餐食。这占据了他所有的精力。
And how did your family feel about it? How did your wife feel about all this?
你的家人怎么想？你妻子对此有什么感觉？
It was difficult for her. I had to pick her up and move her into one of the rent houses. And I moved 52 men into this big old house out in the country. So there was a lot of difficulties for her. And it was hard. It was a lot of stressful situation.
对她来说很难。我不得不把她接走，让她搬进我们的一处出租房里。我把52个人搬进了乡下这栋古老的大房子里。所以她面临很多困难。这很难。这是一个充满压力的情况。
But did I just understand right? You moved your wife into a different house so the men could have the house that you and she were living in?
但我理解对了吗？你把你妻子搬到了另一栋房子，好让工人们能住进你和她住的房子？
Right. Right.
对。对。
Did you know people who just thought, wow, this is nuts what you're doing? Maybe even people in your own church?
有没有人觉得，哇，你做的这些简直疯了？甚至是你自己教堂里的人？
Oh, sure. Sure. Sure. We didn't become popular for doing this, or even praised, really. There's been a lot of hurt and distance, people that we felt like-- and they were our friends. But I think sometimes there's still more prejudice in us than we really realize. Our churches have been good to help foreign missions, but when the foreign comes into our own district, our own comfort area, we're not always ready to accept.
哦，当然。当然。当然。我们并没有因为做这件事而变得受欢迎，甚至没有得到真正的赞美。有很多伤害和疏远，那些我们感觉像是——他们本是我们的朋友。但我认为有时候我们身上的偏见比我们意识到的还要多。我们的教堂一直很乐于资助海外传教，但当外国来到我们自己的地区、我们自己的舒适区时，我们并不总是准备好接受。
And what would these people say to you?
这些人对你说什么？
Well, there were ministers, because we weren't successful real quick in getting help and visas, and they just felt like it wasn't God's will that I did what I did. Because we weren't real successful in the first part of our efforts to help these guys. It took a while.
嗯，有些牧师，因为我们在获取帮助和签证方面没能快速成功，他们就觉得我做的事情不是上帝的旨意。因为我们在帮助这些人的初步工作中并不真正成功。这花了一些时间。
They're saying that, because it was really hard, that meant that God didn't want this to happen?
他们是说，因为这真的很困难，这意味着上帝不想让这件事发生？
Right. And my theory, my biblical feelings are different than probably most people. To me, the gospel and ministering and our faith should be very incorporated. And I know we can't help everybody, but I think everybody is given a little portion that they can do. And I know we can't turn around and change the world tomorrow, but just what's put in our little field here, our little corner, I feel like we're responsible for. So I felt like that was put in my corner.
对。而我的理论，我的圣经感受与大多数人可能不同。对我来说，福音、事工和我们的信仰应该很好地结合在一起。我知道我们不能帮助每一个人，但我认为每个人都被赋予了自己能做的一小部分。我知道我们不能一夜之间扭转乾坤改变世界，但就在这儿，在我们的田地里，在我们的这个小角落，我觉得我们要负责。所以我感到那是被放在了我的角落。
Mark did end up getting a lot of help, including legal help from Catholic charities. And there were private donors in some churches. And at some point, the federal government stepped in. A lawyer from the Equal Opportunity Employment Commission joined the case, and ended up running a lot of it. At last, Kent could get his photocopies out of Kinko's, and pay for somebody to take depositions. It takes a year before all of this came to trial, and for that year, the men lived together in this house that Mark lent them, not working, not sure what was going to happen to them, and incredibly, most of them not telling their families anything, not even that they were out of a job.
马克最终确实得到了很多帮助，包括来自天主教慈善机构的法律援助。还有一些教堂的私人捐助者。在某个时候，联邦政府介入了。一名来自平等就业机会委员会的律师加入了这个案子，最终接手了大部分工作。终于，肯特可以把复印件从金考店取出来，并付钱请人做取证工作。这一切花了整整一年才上庭，在这一年里，工人们住在一起，马克借给他们的那栋房子里，不工作，不确定会发生什么，令人难以置信的是，他们大多数人没有告诉家人任何事情，甚至没说他们失业了。
I just was lying to my wife a lot.
我只是对妻子撒了很多谎。
Yeah, they don't know about that. Because our aim is to make our family happy.
是的，他们不知道。因为我们的目的是让家人幸福。
I told my wife in secret. I didn't talk to my parents. My father, he has heart troubles. And I said, don't tell him, because he's going to upset.
我私下告诉了我妻子。我没告诉父母。我父亲，他有心脏问题。我说，别告诉他，因为他会难过的。
Now, John Pickle and the people who ran his company have their own version of this whole story. And we contacted Pickle, Pickle's lawyers, and three other company officials, and none of them wanted to come on the air to talk about any of this. I spoke with Pickle and one of his managers at length on the phone. They mostly repeated things that they'd already said in court, but declined to say the same things on the radio. Their version of the story is that the Indians, all 52 of them, are lying. Here's reporter John Bowe.
现在，约翰·皮克尔和经营他公司的人对整个故事有自己的版本。我们联系了皮克尔、皮克尔的律师以及其他三位公司官员，他们都不想在广播中谈论任何这些事情。我和皮克尔以及他的一位经理在电话里详细交谈过。他们大多重复了他们在法庭上已经说过的话，但拒绝在电台上说同样的事情。他们的版本是，印度人，全部52个，都在撒谎。这是记者约翰·鲍伊。
All of the top brass at the Pickle Company supported the boss. And they said that the Indian workers had turned on them, and they were lying in a scheme to get visas and green cards to stay in the US. What they kept saying, over and over again, was these guys read about slavery, and they read about trafficking cases on the internet. And that's how they found out how to do this scam, that they would cry "slavery, slavery," and then all these do-gooders would rush in, including the federal government, and give them green cards. And they could stay in the US forever.
皮克尔公司的所有高层都支持老板。他们说印度工人背叛了他们，他们是在撒谎，目的是为了获得签证和绿卡留在美国。他们反复说的是，这些家伙在网上读了关于奴隶制和人口贩运案的内容。这就是他们学会如何进行这个骗局的方法，即他们会哭喊“奴隶制，奴隶制”，然后所有这些慈善家就会蜂拥而至，包括联邦政府，给他们绿卡。然后他们就能永远留在美国了。
That's because of a 2000 law called the Trafficking Victims Protection Act. If you're a foreign worker in a human trafficking case, it says, you get a special visa, called a T-visa, that lets you stay in the country while the case works its way through the courts, which means years. So with that in mind, John Pickle says that everything the men allege is a lie, as part of this scam to stay in the United States. He says that the food in the plant was good, that the men were free to come and go, and that the deal that the Indians signed up for was not, as all 52 Indians claim, to come and work long-term in the US, but to get six months training in Tulsa before being shipped to Kuwait.
这是因为2000年的一项法律，名为《人口贩运受害者保护法》。它规定，如果你是一个人口贩运案件中的外国劳工，你将获得一种特殊的签证，叫做T签证，允许你在案件进行司法程序时留在国内，这意味着几年时间。考虑到这一点，约翰·皮克尔说，工人们指控的一切都是谎言，是这个留在美国骗局的一部分。他说工厂里的食物很好，工人们可以自由来去，而且印度人签署的协议并不是像所有52个印度人声称的那样是来美国长期工作，而是为了在被运往科威特之前在塔尔萨接受六个月的培训。
His argument did not carry the day in court. In a 100-page opinion, the judge found Pickle guilty of a laundry list of violations. There's fraud and false imprisonment, employment and labor law violations having to do with harsh working conditions and living conditions and the minimum wage. And the Indian workers won their discrimination case for being treated so differently than the American workers. In fact, the Pickle case has become a precedent, a way to go after human trafficking and forced labor in court without actually bringing human trafficking charges, which are criminal charges and harder to prove. Again, reporter John Bowe.
他的论点在法庭上没有占上风。在一份100页的裁决意见书中，法官裁定皮克尔犯有一系列违规行为。包括欺诈、非法监禁、以及与恶劣工作条件、生活条件和最低工资有关的就业和劳工法违规。印度工人们赢得了关于被与美国工人们区别对待的歧视诉讼。事实上，皮克尔案已经成为一个先例，一种在法庭上追究人口贩运和强迫劳动的方法，而无需实际提出人口贩运指控，因为那些是更难证明的刑事指控。再次请听记者约翰·鲍伊。
Pickle is assessed a fine of over $1 million. And I called him up a while after that, and asked him how he felt about all that. And he kind of chuckled into the phone. He said, well, let's just say that I'm a guy who lives with his wife in a nice house. And the house is in her name. And basically he said, if they want to come after me for that money, they can, but good luck.
皮克尔被处以超过100万美元的罚款。那之后我给他打电话，问他对此有何感想。他在电话里轻笑了两声。他说，嗯，我们只能说，我是一个和妻子住在一栋好房子里的家伙。房子在她的名下。他基本上说，如果他们想为那笔钱来找我，他们可以试试，但祝他们好运。
Recently, Kent Felty has started the process of going after that money. The $1.3 million that Pickle owes the Indians isn't really much cash. It comes out to less than $25,000 for each of the 52 workers. But even if they don't get Pickle's money, the workers got what they wanted in the first place, thanks to John Pickle. It's only because Pickle tried to exploit them that they ended up in court, and now have visas that let them work and live legally in the United States. [? Joseph ?] now pulls in $28 an hour, which seems typical for these guys. He's brought over his wife and his son, just like he'd hoped for. He thanks Mark Massey.
最近，肯特·费尔蒂已经开始了追讨这笔钱的程序。皮克尔欠印度工人的130万美元现金并不多。算下来52名工人每人不到2.5万美元。但即使他们没有拿到皮克尔的钱，工人们也得到了他们最初想要的，多亏了约翰·皮克尔。只有因为皮克尔试图剥削他们，他们才最终走上了法庭，现在拥有了让他们能合法在美国工作和生活的签证。受访者现在时薪28美元，这对这些伙计们来说很典型。他把妻子和儿子接了过来，就像他希望的那样。他感谢马克·梅西。
In the Bible study, there is a good Samaritan. He is the one. You know what I mean?
在圣经学习中，有一个好撒马利亚人。他就是那个人。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That is a good Samaritan. One man, laying down in the street. Nobody will help. The Bible says a good Samaritan comes over there and takes him.
那是一个好撒马利亚人。一个人，躺在街上。没有人会帮忙。圣经说一个好撒马利亚人走了过来，带着他。
And that's what Mark was.
而那正是马克所做的。
Yes, that's what Mark was.
是的，那就是马克所做的。
It's interesting that, when you met Mark at first, you didn't trust him.
有趣的是，你刚见到马克时，并不信任他。
Yeah. I had doubts. I had doubts, that's all.
是的。我有怀疑。我只是有怀疑。
Yeah.
是的。
But he helped us.
但他帮了我们。
None of us have gotten a dollar, but I think every single person would do it again.
我们当中没一个人拿到一分钱，但我认为每一个人都会愿意再做一次。
Kent Felty says that his life's been transformed by the experience. His law practice is about immigrants and people who hire them. Mark Massey has also made cases like these Indians into his full-time job. Everybody came out better, except Pickle, who lost his business because of the case.
肯特·费尔蒂说，他的人生通过这次经历得到了转变。他的法律业务现在专注于移民和雇佣他们的人。马克·梅西也把像这些印度人一样的案件变成了他的全职工作。除了皮克尔，每个人都变得更好了，因为这个案子他失去了生意。
Back in the beginning of all this, Pickle and the Indians found each other because each of them had a certain stereotyped idea about the other's country. Pickle saw India as filled with impoverished people living on a handful of rice a day. They saw America as prosperous and full of opportunity and fair. In the end, not only was Pickle wrong about them and their country, he was wrong about his own country, too, and what he could get away with here. And the Indians, maybe because they were lucky and found all the people who helped them, it turns out the Indians were right about America.
在这一切开始之初，皮克尔和印度人之所以能找到彼此，是因为他们各自对对方的国家都有一定的刻板印象。皮克尔眼中的印度充满了每天靠几把米生活的贫困人口。他们眼中的美国繁荣、机会多且公平。最终，皮克尔不仅误解了他们和他们的国家，他也误解了自己的国家，以及他在这里能逃避什么。而印度人，也许是因为他们幸运并找到了所有帮助他们的人，事实证明，印度人对美国的看法是对的。
John Bowe's book, which tells this whole story, is called Nobodies: Modern American Slave Labor and the Dark Side of the New Global Economy.
讲述整个故事的约翰·鲍伊的书名为《无名氏：现代美国奴隶劳工与新全球经济的阴暗面》。
Coming up, what do you do when your gut says no, but your boss at the local TV station says yes, yes, yes? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，当你的直觉说“不”，但你当地电视台的老板却说“是，是，是”时，你该怎么办？芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Competition. We have stories today about market forces and the things that they lead people to do. We've arrived at Act Two of our show.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目主题是“竞争”。我们今天有关于市场力量以及它们引导人们做出的行为的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, The Race for Second Place. When TV stations go after each other-- like when any kind of companies go after each other-- there's fallout in random people's lives. Boise, Idaho had four TV stations doing local news. One station dominated the ratings, a local NBC affiliate, so everybody else was fighting to be number two. Thanh Tan was a reporter at the CBS affiliate, Channel 2, and she tells what happened. A warning to listeners that this story mentions, in a very non-graphic way, the existence of sex.
第二幕，争夺第二名的竞赛。当电视台相互竞争时——就像任何公司相互竞争一样——会对普通人的生活造成后果。爱达荷州博伊西有四家电视台在做本地新闻。一家当地NBC附属电视台在收视率上占据主导地位，所以其他所有台都在争夺第二名。谭清曾是CBS附属台Channel 2的一名记者，她讲述了发生的事情。对听众的一个警告：这个故事提到了，以一种非常非图形的方式，性的存在。
Back in October 2005, I was working as a TV news reporter in Boise, Idaho. My station's closest competitor for the number-two rating spot was the ABC affiliate, Channel 6. We couldn't afford to get beaten on anything. On this one day in October, we got wind of what sounded like a really solid story. It had a clear, concise conflict, exactly what we like to cover. Our competitors got wind of it, too. We were two stations with the same exact information, same name, same guy, same everything. But we came to completely different conclusions about what to do with the information.
2005年10月，我在爱达荷州博伊西做电视新闻记者。我所在的电台在争夺第二名收视率位置时的最紧密竞争对手是ABC附属台Channel 6。我们经不起任何失败。10月的这一天，我们听到了一条听起来非常扎实的故事。它有一个清晰、简洁的冲突，正是我们喜欢报道的那种。我们的竞争对手也听到了风声。两家电视台拿着完全相同的信息、相同的名字、相同的人、所有的一切。但我们对如何利用这些信息得出了完全不同的结论。
Let's start with the competition.
让我们从竞争开始。
My name is Scott Picken, P-I-C-K-E-N. I am the news director for KIVI, Channel 6 news.
我叫斯科特·皮肯，拼写是P-I-C-K-E-N。我是Channel 6新闻的新闻总监。
6 On Your Side has learned tonight, a registered sex offender works with children at Idaho Ice World as a referee.
“6号台在你身边”今晚获悉，一名注册性犯罪者在爱达荷冰上世界担任裁判，与儿童一起工作。
It actually started out, believe it or not, as a viewer tip. Somebody had, I believe, emailed me and said that they had become aware that Mr. Kimball, who was a registered sex offender in the state of Idaho, was I believe coaching youth hockey at Idaho Ice World.
信不信由你，它实际上是从一个观众爆料开始的。有人，我相信，给我发了电子邮件说他们得知金博尔先生，爱达荷州的注册性犯罪者，我相信他在爱达荷冰上世界执教少年曲棍球。
He was a referee, actually.
他其实是裁判。
And so I thought that was kind of weird. So we checked it out and found out it was true.
所以我认为这有点怪。我们核实了一下，发现是真的。
--a concerned viewer, and tonight we've confirmed it's true. Brandi Smith joins us live with a story you'll see only on 6. Brandi?
——一位关心的观众，今晚我们确认这是真的。布兰迪·史密斯现场连线，为您带来只有在6号台才能看到的故事。布兰迪？
Michelle, yes, James Kimball does work here as a referee at Idaho Ice World. He's a convicted sex offender. He was convicted--
米歇尔，是的，詹姆斯·金博尔确实在这里工作，担任爱达荷冰上世界的裁判。他是一名被定罪的性犯罪者。他被判刑——
I remember the email. I remember going out on the story, going to Ice World.
我记得那封邮件。我记得去报道那个故事，去冰上世界。
Here's the Channel 6 reporter, Brandi Smith. She doesn't work at the station anymore.
这是Channel 6的记者，布兰迪·史密斯。她已经不在那个电台工作了。
And back at the newsroom, they were researching more about the documents about the charges, if I remember right. And I remember having to go through Ice World and ask people what their response was. And I could only get one woman to comment. And she was pretty outraged, as any parent would be if you heard that a sex offender was working with your kids.
在新闻编辑室里，他们正在研究更多关于指控的文件，如果我没记错的话。我记得我不得不去冰上世界询问人们的回应。我只采访到了一名女性。她非常愤怒，任何家长如果听说性犯罪者在和他们的孩子一起工作，都会感到愤怒。
Fire him. Get rid of him. Get him away from children.
炒了他。除掉他。让他离孩子远点。
At Idaho Ice World, many parents had this same reaction when we told them one of the referees here has a rap sheet that includes--
在爱达荷冰上世界，许多家长在我们要告诉他们这里的一位裁判有包括——在内的前科时，也有同样的反应。
I was the Brandi at Channel 6's competitor, Channel 2. But I didn't do the story. The tip had come late in the day, and what I'd been able to find out was that Jim Kimball was a registered sex offender. The charge was statutory rape, but the case was from 1992, 13 years earlier. It was too late to look up his file at the courthouse, so we decided to hold off a day until we could get the details of what happened. Maybe it was more complicated than it sounded. I'd actually heard of cases in Idaho where boyfriends were charged with having sex with their underage girlfriends. Meanwhile, Channel 6 kept going with a second report.
我是Channel 6竞争对手Channel 2的布兰迪。但我没有做这个报道。爆料是当天很晚才来的，我能查到的是吉姆·金博尔是一名注册性犯罪者。指控是法定强奸，但那起案件发生在1992年，是13年前的事了。去法院查他的档案太晚了，所以我们决定推迟一天，直到能得到事情经过的细节。也许它比听起来更复杂。我实际上听说过爱达荷州有男友被指控与未成年女友发生性关系的案例。与此同时，Channel 6继续进行了第二轮报道。
--offender. He was convicted in 1992 of statutory rape of a child under 16. He is just a subcontractor. He doesn't work with the city of Boise directly. Also, he doesn't work with children directly. He's a referee, and the GM says at any time, there are at least two or three officials on the ice, and that it's very unlikely that Kimball would have any one-on-one time with children, that he would be left alone with them at all. Now, again, this--
——罪犯。他于1992年被判对16岁以下儿童犯有法定强奸罪。他只是一个分包商。他不是直接为博伊西市工作。而且，他不直接与儿童一起工作。他是一名裁判，总经理说在任何时候，冰面上至少有两到三名官员，金博尔不太可能与儿童有任何一对一的时间，更不用说让他们单独在一起了。现在，再次，这个——
Well, I felt the initial concern of a sex offender working with children at Ice World was completely valid.
嗯，我觉得性犯罪者在冰上世界与儿童一起工作的初步担忧是完全有效的。
Here's Brandi again.
这是布兰迪再次说话。
But as the day progressed, I think we learned more about what the charge was, how long ago it had been. And by the time the live shot rolled around, I just remember voicing concern to my photographer. And I just kept commenting to Lance, we're ruining this guy's life. We're ruining his life.
但随着一天过去，我认为我们了解了更多关于指控的内容，了解了那件事发生多久了。当现场报道开始时，我只记得对我的摄影师表示担忧。我一直对兰斯评论，我们毁了这个人的生活。我们毁了他的生活。
At the time, I was actually just doing some work on my computer, and it was just before 5 o'clock. It was literally five minutes of 5:00, just before they go on the air.
当时，我其实只是在电脑上做些工作，那是下午5点前。离5点只有5分钟，就在他们播出前。
And here's the guy who all the fuss was about, Jim Kimball.
这就是整场骚动的中心人物，吉姆·金博尔。
And I actually got a call from an attorney friend of mine who was our state risk manager for Idaho amateur hockey. And he said, look out.
我实际上接到了一位律师朋友的电话，他是我们爱达荷业余曲棍球的国家风险经理。他说，当心。
Jim's a 39-year-old hockey and football fanatic, husband and father of two. He didn't know it, but news editors all over the state were deciding that day whether to wreak havoc with his life, to dredge his name up for a crime he'd committed 13 years earlier. He was at a point in his life where he thought the story was behind him.
吉姆是一个39岁的曲棍球和橄榄球狂热分子，是一个丈夫和两个孩子的父亲。他不知道，全州的新闻编辑们那一天都在决定是否要毁掉他的生活，是否要为他13年前犯下的罪行挖出他的名字。他正处于人生中认为那个故事已经成为过去的一个阶段。
Well, my first reaction was, I think my stomach fell somewhere down around my toes. I'm like, who-- I had all these-- basically, I was a walking question mark. I didn't know who or what or why. And that night I think my wife was working a little bit late, so I phoned her and said, we've got a problem here.
嗯，我的第一反应是，我想我的胃掉到了脚趾头附近。我心想，谁——我有很多——基本上，我是一个行走的问号。我不知道是谁、是什么、为什么。那天晚上我想我妻子加班稍微晚一点，所以我打电话给她说，我们这里有麻烦了。
So here's where, after day one of the Channel 6 coverage, the two stations diverged for good on the Kimball story. I went to the courthouse the next day and got his case file. I found out Jim was 23 at the time, his alleged victim a 15-year-old girl. But looking closely at his record, I found out he wasn't actually a convicted sex offender, as Channel 6 had been reporting. The judge on the case had withheld judgment for three years.
所以这里，在Channel 6报道的第一天之后，两家电视台在金博尔故事上彻底分道扬镳了。第二天我去了法院拿到了他的案件档案。我发现吉姆当时23岁，所谓的受害者是一个15岁的女孩。但仔细查看他的记录，我发现他实际上并不是Channel 6报道中所说的“定罪性犯罪者”。该案法官对该判决搁置了三年。
There were conditions. Jim did 90 days in a work-release program, took classes for sex offenders, and was on probation. At the end of the three years, the same judge dismissed the case. But Channel 6 wasn't reporting that part. Because of a technicality, Jim still had to register as a sex offender, even though his charge had been dismissed. The hockey association that hired him knew all about his record. He never lied about it.
有条件。吉姆在工作释放项目中做了90天，参加了性犯罪者课程，并在试用期。三年期满后，同一名法官驳回了该案件。但Channel 6并没有报道那部分。由于一个技术细节，吉姆仍然必须作为性犯罪者登记，尽管他的指控已被驳回。雇用他的曲棍球协会非常清楚他的记录。他从来没有撒谎。
I talked it over with my news director, and we decided this wasn't a thing, not in 2005. My station, Channel 2, never did the story, neither did Channel 7, or Channel 12, or the AP, or the Idaho Statesman , or the local radio stations. But Channel 6, our closest competitor, kept at it day after day. My news director at the time was Mark Browning. He watched it all in the newsroom, knowing his boss downstairs was watching it, too.
我和我的新闻总监商量了，我们决定这不是个新闻，至少2005年不是。我所在的频道Channel 2从来没做这个故事，Channel 7、Channel 12、美联社、《爱达荷政治家报》或当地电台也没做。但我们的最紧密竞争对手Channel 6却日复一日地坚持报道。当时我的新闻总监是马克·布朗宁。他在新闻室看着这一切，也知道楼下的老板也在看。
Did you feel a pounding in those days after the initial story broke?
在最初的故事爆发后的那些天里，你感到有压力吗？
I did. And I remember some of the talk within the newsroom, and even within the discussions with our management team, said, did we miss one here? In our hesitancy to be ultra-correct, did we miss one here? And we still were very confident there was no story there. But it was hard, from a competitive standpoint. And in our situation, we were a distant number-three station. We needed wins like that, with so-called big stories, to be able to go to the people and say, look, this is what you miss by not watching Channel 2.
我感到过。我记得新闻室内部甚至在与管理团队讨论时，有人说，我们漏掉了一个吗？在我们犹豫要不要做到绝对正确时，我们是否漏掉了什么？但我们仍然非常自信那里没有新闻。但从竞争的角度来看，这很难。在我们的情况下，我们是遥遥落后的第三名。我们需要那种所谓大新闻的胜利，才能去告诉人们，看，这就是你不看Channel 2所错过的。
The two news directors simply had two different ideas about whether Kimball deserved to have his face appear in living rooms all over his hometown. My boss, Mark, thought the guy had paid for his crime, and there was no reason to humiliate him all over again.
两位新闻总监只是对于金博尔是否应该让自己的脸出现在家乡各处的客厅里，有着完全不同的想法。我的老板马克认为这个家伙已经为他的罪行付出了代价，没有理由让他再被羞辱一次。
Big difference, in my book, between sexual predator and sexual offender. But you attach that word "sexual" in front of it, and it changes the entire dynamic with people. And I think what it does is it gives newsrooms license to hunt, where really there's no game there.
在我看来，性掠夺者和性犯罪者之间有巨大的区别。但你在它前面加上“性”这个词，它就改变了人们的整个动态。我认为这样做是给新闻编辑室发了猎杀许可证，而实际上那里并没有猎物。
Scott, at Channel 6, he thought the guy basically had it coming. Jim was driving a school bus when this happened, and the girl he tried to have sex with was a student on his route. To Scott, this was a breach of public trust that shouldn't be forgiven, regardless of whether the charge had been dismissed.
在Channel 6的斯科特认为这个家伙基本上是咎由自取。吉姆开校车时发生了这件事，而他试图与之发生关系的女孩是他路线上的学生。对斯科特来说，这是一种不应该被原谅的对公众信任的背叛，不管指控是否已被驳回。
Whatever the legal standing, he did it. He did it. And to Joe Smith out there, the legalities of the thing are not really as relevant as the fact that this is a man who violated a trust, and did something that, frankly, I would have never done, and I think that most men put in a position of trust like that don't contemplate doing. He made a decision. He made a conscious decisions. This wasn't like an accidental act of sex. That's the kind of decision that's going to affect him for the rest of his life.
不管法律地位如何，他确实做了。他确实做了。对普通老百姓来说，事情的合法性并不像这是一个辜负了信任的人，做了一件坦率地说我永远不会做的事，而且我认为大多数男人处在那样的信任位置上都不会考虑去做的事，这事实那样重要。他做出了决定。他做出了有意识的决定。这不像偶然的性行为。那是一种将影响他余生的决定。
There was another angle to Jim's story, which is what allowed it to live on for days. Jim worked for a city-owned ice rink, but he was hired by a subcontractor. Back when he applied for the job, the subcontractor had automatically denied his application because of his record, but they encouraged him to appeal the decision, and he did. A state panel found that Jim wasn't a risk to kids, and he got the job. But city officials said they didn't know any of this until Channel 6 aired the story. On camera, they said they would review their hiring policy. So for Scott, the story became a TV news trifecta. It had a dubious main character, a public accountability angle, and the bonus of a possible policy change.
吉姆的故事还有另一个角度，这正是它能存活数天的原因。吉姆为市属溜冰场工作，但他是由分包商雇佣的。当他申请这份工作时，分包商因为他的记录自动拒绝了他的申请，但他们鼓励他申诉这个决定，他确实这么做了。一个州小组发现吉姆对孩子没有风险，他得到了这份工作。但市政府官员说，直到Channel 6播出了这个故事，他们才知道任何这些情况。在镜头前，他们说他们会审查他们的招聘政策。所以对斯科特来说，这个故事成了电视新闻的“三冠王”。它有一个可疑的主角，一个公共问责的角度，以及可能发生的政策改变的加分项。
Scott wrote a memo to the staff congratulating them on their work. They had what we in the TV news business might refer to as a win. Brandi, the reporter, should have been feeling great. Instead, she felt awful.
斯科特给员工写了一份备忘录，祝贺他们的工作。他们完成了我们在电视新闻业可能称之为“胜利”的东西。记者布兰迪本该感觉很好。相反，她感觉糟透了。
This guy had a clean record from then until now. A judge had withheld judgment on the charge. A board of several people had decided he was OK to work with children. So where do I come in and say, no, that's not right? We were doing more damage to his life than we were benefiting the community. So why are we doing the story, besides to damage this man? And I called the newsroom and said, I just don't know. I'm not certain that we should go with this. And I don't remember if it was our executive producer or if it was Scott just saying, you have to do this. And I said, I don't want to.
这个人在那之后到现在一直有干净的记录。一名法官搁置了对该指控的判决。几个人组成的一个委员会已经决定他适合与儿童一起工作。那我凭什么站出来说，不，那是不对的？我们对他的生活造成的损害要多于我们给社区带来的利益。所以我们为什么要报道这个故事，除了损害这个人？我打电话给新闻室说，我不知道。我不确定我们是否应该报道这个。我不记得是我们的执行制片人还是斯科特说，你必须做这件事。我说，我不想做。
And it was, you're doing the story. Get over it, you're doing the story. Stop complaining. You're out there. You're going to go live in 15 minutes. That's it.
对方就是：你去做那个报道。别管它，你去做那个报道。别再抱怨了。你在外面。你还有15分钟就要现场直播了。就是这样。
Scott remembers the argument, but from his point of view, Brandi just didn't understand the bigger picture of what he was trying to do.
斯科特记得那次争论，但在他看来，布兰迪只是不理解他试图做的更大画面。
Brandi, when she was here-- and I love Brandi to death, but she was extremely young, and was very inexperienced. And this is not meant to be an insult on Brandi or anyone here, but the fact of the matter is that in order to become a viable journalistic organization in this market, we had to step up our game some. And I think sometimes people need to understand that, just because you're uncomfortable with something, or just because you're being asked to do something that's not in your realm, doesn't necessarily make it incorrect or wrong. It just means you have to go to the next level. You have to take it to a new level.
布兰迪在的时候——我爱布兰迪爱得要死，但她非常年轻，非常缺乏经验。这并不是对布兰迪或这里的任何人侮辱，但事实是，为了成为这个市场上可行的记者组织，我们必须提升水平。我认为有时候人们需要理解，仅仅因为你对某事感到不舒服，或者仅仅因为被要求做一些不在你领域内的事情，并不一定意味着它是不正确的或错误的。这只意味着你必须上升到下一个级别。你必须把它提升到一个新的水平。
For Scott, Jim Kimball was the next level. This story was exactly the kind of thing he wanted his reporters to be doing every day. Scott had been hired at Channel 6 just two weeks earlier. His bosses felt the station was going nowhere. Scott was supposed to turn it all around. His strategy was to make what he calls a hard-nose convenience play, which means a lot of short hard-news stories packed into 10-minute chunks. The station dropped its 6 On Your Side slogan, and became Today's Channel 6 News.
对斯科特来说，吉姆·金博尔就是那个“下一个级别”。这个故事正是他希望他的记者每天都在做的东西。斯科特两周前才被聘为Channel 6。他的老板们觉得这个台毫无起色。斯科特被委以重任去扭转局面。他的策略是进行他所谓的“硬碰硬便捷游戏”，这意味着在10分钟的时间段内塞入大量简短的硬新闻故事。该台放弃了“6号台在你身边”的口号，变成了“今日6号台新闻”。
When I first walked in Channel 6, I had never walked into a newsroom in my life that had as much of an inferiority complex as this one did. They just all looked over and they said, we're never going to be as good as the other guys. We're never going to do better. We're never going to win. So it was a very, very depressing place. And I walked in there and said, you know what, you're not only going to be as good as Channel 7, you're going to be better. Every day, every minute you're on the air, you're going to be better. You're going to work twice as hard. You're going to produce three times more work than they do.
当我第一次走进Channel 6时，我这辈子从没进过一个像这家这样有强烈自卑感的新闻室。他们只是看着说，我们永远不会像其他人一样好。我们永远不会做得更好。我们永远不会赢。所以那是一个非常、非常令人沮丧的地方。我走进那里说，你知道吗，你们不仅会像7号台一样好，你们会变得更好。每天，每分钟你们在播出时，你们都会更好。你们会工作得更努力。你们会制作出比他们多三倍的工作量。
And there was a lot of pressure. This new guy comes in. You never know what he plans to do with reporters. You never know what he plans to do with anchors. The entire newsroom was in upheaval, essentially. So there was a sense that everyone was trying to prove themselves to him. We need to stay. You need to keep us as a reporter. Please don't fire us.
压力很大。这个新家伙进来了。你永远不知道他打算对记者做什么。你永远不知道他打算对主播做什么。整个新闻室基本上处于动荡之中。所以每个人都有种试图向他证明自己的感觉。我们需要留下来。你得留下我们做记者。请别解雇我们。
Under her previous boss, Brandi was supposed to deliver a story from a live location during her shift, which was the night shift. And even then, she didn't go live every single night. Under Scott, that requirement tripled. She had to go live at 5:30, 6:00, and 10:00.
在之前的老板手下，布兰迪被要求在她的轮班期间从现场直播地点发送一条故事，那是夜班。即使那样，她也不是每晚都进行直播。在斯科特手下，那个要求翻了三倍。她必须在5点半、6点和10点进行直播。
--On Your Side. We will have the latest for this story tomorrow. Reporting live in Boise, Brandi Smith, 6 On Your Side.
——在你身边。我们将为您带来这个故事的最新消息，明天。在博伊西现场连线，布兰迪·史密斯，“6号台在你身边”。
On the Kimball story, since no other media thought it was worth covering, it became a Channel 6 exclusive, and Scott made sure every anchor mentioned it at every broadcast. Scott says he was signalling to the public that the station was changing, and also trying to boost morale inside the office. They were kicking ass and he wanted everyone to know it.
在金博尔的故事上，由于没有其他媒体认为值得报道，它成了Channel 6的独家新闻，斯科特确保每位主播在每次广播中都提到它。斯科特说他是在向公众发出信号，表明电台正在改变，同时也试图提升办公室内的士气。他们表现出色，他想让每个人都知道这一点。
Brandi Smith is live with the story you'll see only on 6.
布兰迪·史密斯现场连线，为您带来只有在6号台才能看到的故事。
--because of a story you saw only on 6.
——因为您在6号台独家看到的故事。
The move seems to be in response to a 6 On Your Side investigation where we found a registered sex offender was allowed--
这一举动似乎是对“6号台在你身边”调查的回应，在该调查中我们发现一名注册性犯罪者被允许——
It's an exclusive story. Brandi, you've been all over it. I'm sure you'll continue to follow it for us, tell us what the exact--
这是一个独家故事。布兰迪，你一直在报道它。我相信你会继续为我们跟进，告诉我们具体——
They had Brandi go live from Ice World three times that first day. They showed an undated, grainy headshot of Jim, his hair short like a buzz cut. He looks uncomfortable. In later broadcasts, they showed that same picture in black and white, even though the shot in the registry was in color. At one point, the video slowly zooms in to Jim's eyes, fades them in and out. But the thing that really killed Jim was that they juxtaposed his mug shot with video of little kids skating and walking around the rink.
第一天他们让布兰迪从冰上世界进行了三次直播。他们展示了一张未注明日期、颗粒感很重的吉姆大头照，他的头发剪得很短。他看起来很不舒服。在后来的广播中，他们展示了同样照片的黑白版本，尽管登记册上的照片是彩色的。在某个时刻，视频缓慢地聚焦在吉姆的眼睛上，使它们淡入淡出。但真正杀死吉姆的是，他们将他的面部照与小孩子们在溜冰场溜冰和走动的视频并列放在一起。
They're showing Mighty Mite kids that are five, six, seven years old. It makes me look like a pervert, and that I was preying on six- and seven-year-old kids. That's false. And so when I look at that, I'm going, wrong, wrong, wrong. To me, even though, yeah, I have a public record, but I feel in some ways they treated this as like a National Enquirer story, like this is going to draw in viewers. We've got this exclusive.
他们展示的是五、六、七岁的小孩。这让我看起来像个变态，好像我在猎食六、七岁的孩子。那是假的。所以当我看到这些时，我心想，错，错，错。对我来说，虽然，是的，我有公共记录，但我感到在某种程度上他们把这当作《国家询问报》的故事，好像这会吸引观众。我们有这个独家新闻。
Jim's real story isn't the most sympathetic. He lives with his wife and two daughters in a Boise suburb in a modest house in one of those newer cookie-cutter subdivisions. He makes sure his daughters aren't within earshot as he tells me what happened. Jim says he was immature at the time, living at home with his parents. He says he struck up a flirtation with the girl, picked her up at her house one day. They didn't quite have sex, but it amounted to the same thing. He's pretty clear that he was an idiot to have done it.
吉姆的真实故事并不是最令人同情的。他和妻子及两个女儿住在博伊西郊区一个较新的模版式住宅区里的一栋简陋房子里。当他告诉我发生了什么时，他确保女儿们不在听力范围内。吉姆说他当时很不成熟，和父母住在一起。他说他和那个女孩调情，有一天在家里接她。他们没完全发生性关系，但也就差不多了。他很清楚自己当时是个傻瓜。
I don't know what I was thinking at the time. I think the problem was I wasn't thinking at the time, and that's what led to it. I've regretted it every day. And there's probably not a day goes by that you don't think about it, maybe for even just a split second.
我不知道当时在想什么。我想问题是我当时没在思考，这就是导致它的原因。我每天都为此感到后悔。大概没有哪一天你不会想到它，哪怕只是一瞬间。
Before the story broke on Channel 6, things were going pretty well for Jim and his wife, [? Shar. ?] They were working on getting his record expunged. Their daughters were doing well at school. Once the story hit, it was like their lives had exploded. They had to tell friends about the rape charge, and wonder if they'd stay friends. They had to tell their nine-year-old daughter about Jim's mistake, years before they'd planned to, in case people were talking about it at school. They worried that if he attended his daughter's school functions, someone would report him for being around kids, and so he skipped his older daughter's choir concert.
在Channel 6报道这个故事之前，吉姆和他妻子的生活进展得相当顺利。他们正在努力消除他的记录。他们的女儿们在学校表现很好。故事一出来，他们的生活就好像爆炸了。他们不得不告诉朋友关于强奸指控的事情，并怀疑他们是否还会是朋友。他们不得不告诉他们9岁的女儿关于吉姆的错误，比他们计划的早了几年，以防人们在学校谈论这件事。他们担心如果他参加女儿的学校活动，会有人举报他在孩子身边，所以他错过了大女儿的合唱团音乐会。
Jim told me he cried on and off for days. So did his wife. Even talking about it now, she cries.
吉姆告诉我他有好几天一直在哭。他妻子也是。即使现在谈起它，她还是哭了。
?] You know, there's a lot of people that we know, that we'd known for years, that had known us for years, that didn't really understand what had happened and why it happened. They misinterpret the charge. They misinterpret what he is.
你知道，我们认识的很多人，我们认识多年的，了解我们的，他们并不真正了解发生了什么以及为什么发生。他们误解了指控。他们误解了他是什么。
What do you think? When you watched that news coverage, how do you think they depicted your husband?
你怎么看？当你观看那个新闻报道时，你认为他们是如何描述你丈夫的？
?] As a child molester. And that's how people at my work saw it. That's how lot of people saw it. They saw him as a child molester.
像个猥亵儿童的人。这就是我工作的人们看到它的方式。这就是很多人看到它的方式。他们视他为猥亵儿童的人。
What did they say to you?
他们对你说了什么？
?] Primarily, they went to my supervisor. And [? Jade ?] asked me what was going on, and I told her the whole story. And she said, people are asking questions. And I said, just send them to me. I'll talk to them, but--
主要是，他们去找我的主管。杰德问我发生了什么事，我告诉了她整个故事。她说，人们在问问题。我说，让他们直接来找我。我会和他们谈，但是——
Jim's across the room, leaning up against the wall. He looks ashamed and sad.
吉姆在房间对面，靠着墙站着。他看起来既羞愧又难过。
Are you OK, Jim?
你还好吗，吉姆？
Yeah. No, this is fine. Anybody else would have probably told me to go to hell. And rightfully so.
是的。不，这没事。换做别人可能已经叫我去死了。理应如此。
I ?] was ready to two years ago.
我两年前就已经准备好了。
Were you really that close?
你们真的那么接近（崩溃）了吗？
?] When this all came back to the front, like I said, it almost ruined our lives. It really did.
当这一切又回到面前时，就像我说的，它差点毁了我们的生活。真的毁了。
It must have been very difficult to stand by him during that time.
在那段时间里支持他一定非常困难。
It ?] still is.
现在依然是。
After a couple of days, Jim was fired from Ice World.
几天后，吉姆被冰上世界解雇了。
A sex offender working with Treasure Valley children as a hockey referee is off the ice tonight.
一名与宝藏谷儿童一起工作的性犯罪者作为曲棍球裁判，今晚离开了冰面。
The city of Boise suspended James Kimball from Idaho Ice World after 6 On Your Side broke news of his past. Brandi Smith joins us with much more on a story you'll see only on 6. Brandi?
在“6号台在你身边”报道了他的过去后，博伊西市暂停了詹姆斯·金博尔在爱达荷冰上世界的职务。布兰迪·史密斯为您带来只有在6号台才能看到的故事的更多内容。布兰迪？
I think the biggest thing in this whole ordeal was they never once, not one time, ever called to ask my side. So let's not go to the source and let's not go to the person who actually did this. Let's just do a submarine job on him, and the hell with the facts. That's crap reporting.
我想这件事中最重要的一点是，他们一次都没有，一次都没打电话来询问我的立场。所以我们不要去追根溯源，不要去寻找那个真正做这件事的人。让我们只是给他致命一击，去他妈的事实。那是垃圾报道。
Scott Picken, Brandi's boss, says his staff tried to contact Jim but couldn't find a number. In fact, Jim couldn't have been easier to find when the story broke. He's in the phone book. His address is online. But this is the sort of story where if you talk to the person and find out all the facts, it can kill the story.
布兰迪的老板斯科特·皮肯说，他的员工尝试联系吉姆但没找到号码。事实上，当故事爆发时，吉姆完全容易找到。他在电话簿里。他的地址在网上。但这是一种如果你谈话并查明所有事实就可能杀死故事的故事。
I don't remember if we looked him up, if we tried to call him. I don't know that we did.
我不记得我们是否查过他，是否尝试过打电话。我不知道我们有没有。
Why not?
为什么不？
I don't know. I'm sorry, I'm trying to remember. No, I don't think I ever called him. And that was likely bad reporting on my part. I probably ought to have tried to call him and get his side of the story. And I don't know why I didn't.
我不知道。我很抱歉，我正在努力回想。不，我不认为我打过电话。那很可能是我这边的糟糕报道。我大概应该尝试打电话并得到他那边的故事。我不知道为什么我没那么做。
Months after she did the Kimball story, a coworker at Channel 6 told Brandi she should include it on her resume tape. Brandi didn't. It's not a story she's proud of.
在她做完金博尔故事几个月后，Channel 6的一位同事告诉布兰迪她应该把它收录在她的简历带里。布兰迪没有。这不是她引以为傲的故事。
I've been in Brandi's situation more times than I'd like to admit. I've had to cover stories I hated. I've made mistakes. I've smeared people's names because of those mistakes, like the time police gave me the wrong mug shot for a suspect on the run. Yeah. Imagine being that guy. I felt like a dumbass, but it was live TV. There was no time to double-check. You're sometimes assigned three different stories in a day, so at some point, you make do with what you have.
我处于布兰迪这种情况的次数比我想承认的要多。我不得不报道我讨厌的故事。我犯过错。我因为那些错误抹黑了人们，比如有一次警方给了我错误的面部照去通缉一名嫌疑人。是的。想象一下成为那个人。我感觉像个笨蛋，但那是电视直播。没有时间双重核对。你有时一天被分派三个不同的故事，所以到某个时刻，你只能凑合用手头的东西。
Scott stands by their coverage of Jim. He says they acted in good faith, and that's the main thing. Even as he watches the stories with us again on a DVD, it's not the content that bothers him so much as the production value. All he sees is how far they've come.
斯科特坚持他们的报道。他说他们是出于诚意行事，那是主要的事情。即使当他在DVD上和我们一起观看这些报道时，困扰他的不是内容，而是生产价值。他看到的一切都是他们走了多远。
Yeah, the graphics are ugly, to say the least. Michelle, we've done a lot with Michelle in order to change her image and change her look. We've actually worked with cosmetic and look consultants and what have you. We've changed the background of the set, got it less orange and things along those lines. We don't use three-shot desk sets anymore at all. And so things along those lines--
是的，图形很丑，至少可以这么说。米歇尔，我们和米歇尔做了很多工作以改变她的形象和外观。我们实际上和化妆和形象顾问合作过。我们改变了布景背景，减少了橙色之类的东西。我们不再使用三人座办公台了。所以类似的事情——
We've got this saying in the business, "We have to make the black go away," meaning we have to fill the news shows with something. Car crashes and crime are really easy to do. They don't take up resources, and they freak people out, get people talking.
我们在行业里有句谚语，“我们必须让黑色消失”，意思是说我们必须用某种东西填满新闻节目。车祸和犯罪真的很容易做。它们不需要资源，而且会让人们感到恐惧，让人们谈论。
As much as I'd like to say our station came out ahead by not covering the Kimball story, I can't. This coverage worked for Channel 6. It set the stage for their comeback.
尽管我想说我们电台因为没报道金博尔故事而领先，但我不能。这个报道对Channel 6很管用。它为他们的回归奠定了基础。
And the result of that has been numerous awards, an Emmy for Best Newscast, which we are very proud of. And a product which people are watching more and more. Our July book just came in. We are up 75% at 10 o'clock. And I suppose a cynic could say it's all about ratings, it's all about ratings, it's all about ratings. No, it's about more than that.
结果就是无数的奖项，我们非常自豪的最佳新闻节目艾美奖。以及人们越来越喜欢看的产品。我们的七月收视数据刚出来。我们在10点钟增长了75%。我想愤世嫉俗者可能会说这全是关于收视率的，全是关于收视率的，全是关于收视率的。不，它不仅仅是那样。
I have this analogy I like to use sometimes. If a tree falls in the woods and there's not a news crew there to film it, did it happen? And the answer is, well, yes, but who cares? The fact of the matter is is that there's no relevance to it, because no one knows about it. Your stories gain impact, are more valuable, when more people are watching them. And that's the important thing that you need to remember about the drive for ratings. It is not an unworthy goal. It's a very worthy goal.
我有一个类比我喜欢有时使用。如果森林里有一棵树倒下，而那里没有新闻组去拍摄它，它发生了吗？答案是，嗯，是的，但谁在乎呢？事实是，它没有关联，因为没人知道。当你报道的故事有更多人观看时，它们的影响力更大，价值更高。这就是你需要记住的关于追求收视率的重要事情。这不是一个不值得的目标。这是一个非常值得的目标。
If I'd had Scott as my news director instead of Mark, I could have easily been the reporter ordered to stand outside Ice World that day, showing everyone that disturbing picture of Jim. And I have to ask myself whether I would have had the courage to walk away from the story. I hate saying this, but probably not. Scott's convincing, and it's tempting to want to see the business the way he does. If ratings are any measure, a lot of people do.
如果我有斯科特作为新闻总监而不是马克，我很容易就会成为那天被命令站在冰上世界外、展示吉姆那张令人不安照片的记者。我必须问自己，我是否有勇气远离那个故事。我讨厌这么说，但很可能不会。斯科特很有说服力，想要以他的方式看待这个行业很诱人。如果收视率有什么标准的话，很多人确实这么做。
Thanh Tan. She's now a TV reporter in Portland, Oregon.
谭清。她现在是俄勒冈州波特兰市的一名电视记者。
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Bruce Wallace. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
那么，我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔特斯、约翰·杰特、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨负责我们的网站。Seth Lind和布鲁斯·华莱士提供了制作协助。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢名单）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资金捐助名单）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, right before today's show, I went to him and said I wasn't sure about doing that Pickle story. But he told me,
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，就在今天的节目之前，我去找他说我不确定是否要做那个皮克尔故事。但他告诉我，
You're doing the story. Get over it. You're doing the story. Stop complaining. You're going to go live in 15 minutes. That's it.
你去做那个故事。别管它。你去做那个报道。别再抱怨了。你还有15分钟就要现场直播了。就是这样。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
公共广播国际公司，PRI。